well it's not just pupils and parents
facing disruption today industrial
action across the rail network threatens
to cause difficulty for those heading to
work uh joining us now from London's
Houston station is the General Secretary
of the azleth Union Mick Whelan hello
chief Mr Whelan it's always good to see
you thanks for joining us on the program
you've rejected an eight percent pay
rise earlier this year am I right in
saying that
uh we rejected an offer we knew nothing
about that contained a number of red
lines and was off to us through a
process that was outside what we'd
agreed and whatever else and for that we
were told to give up every condition
that we have national and local and they
wouldn't make us redundant until 2024
okay
um I think it was just the posturing and
feeling a bad faith it was deliberately
set up to fail
okay
um I know that I'm guessing that you
deal with the transport secretary as
well as obviously the owners of the
railways that you work on
um has there been any movement
I met with the rail Minister last week
he's facilitating talks we go back in
the talks next week
what are you hoping for from that
who was going you know us we're
optimistic none of us want to be here
the people stand behind me don't want to
be losing money they don't want to be on
a picket line but at the same time after
four years they do believe they deserve
a pay rise
um there's no more money is what we're
being told heard from the education
secretary representing the government
this morning she said you can strike all
you want there's no more money
well in well in case we're going to be
here for a very long haul and as you
know it's about a million people out on
strike today with more people balancing
more people coming on board it's not
just the rail sector it's the Civil
Service it's the fire brigades the
teachers the lecturers it's all the
people we've just been talking to this
morning okay and at some point
something's got to give but let's just
look at my industry for a second we've
got 15 companies out on strike today
every one of them is declaring profits
and everyone is paying dividends but
they're not giving the people that work
with them a pay rise there's something
wrong in that isn't it
the march today on Parliament organized
by the TUC is about this anti-strike
legislation
um you once said that anti-strike
legislation could result in longer
periods of industrial action explain
that to me
well if it takes 10 days to have the
equivalent amount of effect as a one-day
strike or naturally strife's going to
take longer we don't understand how this
bill is going to work in Europe without
minimum strike levels they don't utilize
them all sudden it's gone from being
minimum strike levels or service levels
to minimum safety levels we're in a
safety critical injury there's nothing
about safety involved in any of this
this is just we are already the worst
trade Union laws in Western Europe and
this is just a further thing to just
take away people's right to strike and
their human rights and it's a backdoor
form of indenture and slavery
and Mick would you
um coordinate any Futures strike action
along with other major unions to
coincide with the budget in the middle
of next month if it was necessary
I think there'll be discussion through
the TUC the Affiliates the TC about
future Days of action
um if that's one of the days that those
put a forward we'll be part of that
discussion
sounds as though you're pretty resigned
to
um having to fight more before you get
anywhere near what you're looking for
I think so I think look I think
it's every sector and everywhere is
feeling this and the government has been
in charge of the finances for 12 years
this isn't a new thing and only they can
relax look if they're not paying any pay
Rises there is no wage inflation but if
you do pay pay rise is the battery comes
back in tax and also comes back through
what people spend through vat and
indirect taxes as well it's the benefit
of the economy and benefit of everybody
to give people disposable income that
creates jobs that creates worth a
kick-starts the economy again this idea
that we can have a 26 cut in pay or cost
of living when a week in which food
inflation went for 16.3 was it it's
quite frightening something's got to
give us some point
um and it doesn't look as though it's
going to be your Union anytime soon
thank you for taking the time to join us
on the program this morning as always
much appreciated thank you